we met on Bumble a set of frozen yogurt
date because I said hey it's low
commitment we don't like each other we
can dip in 10 minutes you try to cancel
me the day before the date and so I
called her up and I just said no I just
refused her request to cancel she showed
up we immediately just started talking
about business and at the end of the day
I said hey I don't know if this is going
to work out but you should only work for
me she said no I literally just met you
but she had a whole book of business as
a personal trainer and we'd spoken every
night she said you need to take me on a
date because you promised you're going
to take me somewhere that wasn't
Chipotle Panda Express said yes I said
can you do one favor for me first I just
need you to help me process these
contracts and I had this fat stack of
contracts that we processed like a
hundred and something thousand dollars
she looked at it and she was like what
is this I was like this is the thing I
was telling you about is it legal I was
like yeah she's like all right a minute